my mother thought going to a white
school meant I would get a better
education and I would be safer wrong
that's Joey Caruso a little Thug with a
big chip on his shoulder you know I
managed to avoid him before I wore these
shoes
nice shoes Bojangles
Bojangles
that's not what your mother called me
when I was tap dancing in her drawers
last night
I know you think I'm crazy but if I let
him get away with that he'd be doing it
all year now I couldn't beat him but I
thought maybe I could out black him what
did I start
you know who I am you step on my shoe
again I'm gonna tell you who I am I
don't play that I'm from bed stop boy
I'll bring half of Marcy up in here I
will beat your butt so bad it gonna need
crutches in your sleep hey this might
work no one else I'm gonna do
what's your name Chris
I'm Dr Raymond your new principal I'm
gonna get off my feet
it's funny
that's not funny
what's your name son Caruso pick
yourself up next time you come to my
school
see those shoes
they say something they say I'm a
student I want to learn
I want more of that
less of this
don't bump into me again
even though Caruso was messing with me
getting embarrassed made him even matter
so you know what's coming next this
isn't over
oh he got away with calling me that day
but later in life he said it at a DMX
concert and almost got stomped to death
really from bedside to or die yeah you
ever been shot no well at least not yet
I'm Greg I'm Chris Greg williger wasn't
my first choice for a friend but Mutual
ass kicking seemed to bring people
together cool shoes
you know if that was a new principle
who's the oldest
I didn't touch her I don't know what
they're talking about
Mr Palmer was accused of doing something
that we can't tell you about because of
the network senses the school settled
the lawsuit out of court and he's not
allowed to teach anymore if he moves to
your neighborhood you'll get a warning
after school I had a plan this is crazy
man it's a school fight School fights
only lasts a minute somebody always
comes and breaks them up all I have to
do is get in the first punch
somebody to stop it
should be over any minute
all right
[Music]
somebody gonna stop it
[Applause]
thank you again
come on man come on I got a schedule
there's a kid trying to catch yeah yeah
I see you
wow
that you don't give me tomorrow I bet I
do you do it
back up
I was still hungry but I was almost home
what could go wrong now
[Music]
laughs